VOICE
Okay already!
From J.K. Rowling, the author of
the book series that kept Borders
open for another few years.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Comes the movie adaptation for
people too lazy to read.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Harry Potter.
When an evil noseless freak
threatens to take over the world -
it's up to this boy wizard, his
totally useless friend and his
superior in every way, hot lady
friend... to defeat him.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And when I said hot, I only meant
in the last three movies after she
turned 18. Pervs.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Journey along as they travel to a
magical boarding school where kids
learn potions, spells and
divination... but not English, Math
or Science.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Where technology seems to be frozen
in the 19th century, replacing cell
phones and the internet, with quill
pens and owls.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And where child endangerment is
totally no big deal.
VOICE (CONT'D)
My goodness!
Seriously how have they not shut
this school down yet?
VOICE (CONT'D)
A franchise so epic, it took ten
years, eight films, four directors
and two Dumbledores to tell...
Featuring...
VOICE (CONT'D)
The one that started it all
The one everyone hates
VOICE (CONT'D)
The one everyone loves
The one with shovel face.
VOICE (CONT'D)
The one with the raging hormones
The one where Dumbledore dies
Oh uh, spoiler alert.
VOICE (CONT'D)
The one you can skip
And the one that made adults cry
like little babies
VOICE (CONT'D)
Follow our heroes as they transform
from adorable youngsters struggling
to act
VOICE (CONT'D)
To awkward tweens
To barely legal heartthrobs
'
VOICE (CONT'D)
To young adults pretending to look
like grownups.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Ron really let himself go.
Witness the magic that will dazzle
you with questions like:
If magic is supposed to be secret,
why is their doorway in the most
highly trafficed subway station in
London?
Why are all the bullies in one
house
VOICE (CONT'D)
and why don't they just expel them?
And isn't it disturbing that this
rat on Ron's crotch is actually a
grown man? Ehhugh..
VOICE (CONT'D)
Relive the excitement of acclaimed
british thespians yelling nonsense
VOICE (CONT'D)
Battles that would have been way
cooler with lightsabers... or if
they just moved around a little
more...
VOICE (CONT'D)
And Rupert Grint's dumb face.
Starring...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Luke Sky Potter
Ginger Spice
VOICE (CONT'D)
Your First Erection
Warwick Davis
VOICE (CONT'D)
Professor Hans Gruber
Claudio Miranda
VOICE (CONT'D)
Hairy Old Man
Warwick Davis
VOICE (CONT'D)
Forrest Whitaker
Hodor
VOICE (CONT'D)
Michael Jackson
Lindsay Lohan
VOICE (CONT'D)
Warwick Davis
Vladimir Putin
VOICE (CONT'D)
Larry King
Gandalf the Gay
VOICE (CONT'D)
And Warwick Davis
Harry Potter
VOICE (CONT'D)
So quidditch makes absolutely no sense right? A 150 point ball?
That's just bullshit right there.
Thanks for watching. Be sure to subscribe.
VOICE (CONT'D)
"You shall not pass!"
"I love lamp"
"They're eating her! And then they're going to eat me! Oh My Goood!"
"How's it goin' royal ugly dudes?"
"Allison, I love you. Will you marry me?"
"What the hell is a Hufflepuff?"